boa noite a todos obrigado porque é nada
esta oportunidade de falar o crime sobre
o fogo pois neste momento mais forte que
o álvaro que proporcionam
vamos tentar falar de alguma forma não
tão forte porque já todos assistimos o
fogo foi um evento bastante falado
infelizmente não havia falado durante a
gestão de todos ouvimos todos ouvimos
falar muita gente sobrevive e só pelas
marcas hoje meu tema chama-se viver com
forro e ia chamar também evoluir com o
fogo porque o fato é disso que se trata
há mais ou menos 50 mil anos o homem deu
um salto muito grande da evolução dela e
viu o assalto
não só por isso claro aos que não foi
por isso mas muito ajudá-lo porque
aprendeu a dominar um dos momentos mais
fortes na natureza o fogo do qual tinha
pavor
como é normal como todos temos nós
quando vivemos situações de ensino e tem
sido de extrema confiança de estado em
portugal e portanto a partir desse
momento o homem que é uma uma evolução
bastante forte ao longo dos tempos e
trabalhar muito com esse argumento foi
uma ajuda muito grande para digamos
domésticas alguma forma entre parênteses
a natureza isto porque porque primeiro
utilizou para caçar importante para
caçar animais selvagens o fogo era um
ótimo tenha sido por conduzir os animais
para o ano o homem queria que o esforço
porque era mais fácil cassar ou não
tinha trabalho nenhum era só pegar o seu
fim
bastava para a pastorícia para preparar
territórios para pastores e para a
renovação de pastagens para abrir zona
sul e depois ainda faz de ser um animal
solitário para a preparação do
território para a agricultura forma que
não haja utilizava em alguns territórios
nosso planeta e portanto com tanto o uso
de fogo e em particular no nosso clima
clima mediterrânico apesar de nós não
seremos vaiados posto de danny
temos uma forte influência desse clima
que tem uma particularidade única do
mundo em que a estação mais quente do
ano com esse conhecido com a estação
mais seca do ano nós temos em outra
particularidade na maior parte dos
países concluiu o britânico está
tentando falar todos os países da bacia
mediterrânica
da califórnia do sul na áfrica do sul
sede da província do cabo e da austrália
só os livros digitais no mundo têm essa
particularidade que nós que vivemos com
ela que sempre com ela nos parece normal
de facto conhecido o período mais quente
cumprido mais recuado
ao contrário dos outros países da bacia
mediterrânica sobre os norte da áfrica
do sul do centro médico
nós temos uma influência também
atlântica e que nos dá essa influência
política nas mãos dadas muita chuva
durante o período em que temos chuva
tanto a sec é igual à da seca não há
chuva e aquilo que temos quando tem
chuva que temos territórios no centro e
norte do país que tem mais ou menos
grosso modo entre 1.500 milímetros água
e dois mil e quinhentos ou seja temos
muito mais chuva até mesmo parte dos
outros países que estão de fato na bacia
mediterrânica
isso deu uma facilidade muito grande o
uso do fogo como temos um produto
cultural é fácil de utilizar e como
temos vegetação que pois tem muita água
e se desenvolve rapidamente
portanto nós ao longo do tempo fomos
habituando a nossa natureza e ela nós
próprios de fogo e recomprar com fogo e
portanto temos um ecossistema que está
extremamente adaptado ao fogo e portanto
aquilo que nós precisaremos hoje
continuar a evoluir fogo mas já há uma
perspectiva diferente e não temos
evoluído temos que largar o livro porque
se calhar hoje porque temos tantos
incêndios rurais por continuamos usar o
for muito às vezes indevidamente
inconscientemente como se ainda
tivéssemos nessas alturas porque tivemos
muita legislação muitos enquadramento
que deixou quase digamos pode dizer que
dirigiu utilizações racionais do fogo o
que dificulta por organizações
internacionais
nesta quarta também podemos dizer que
temos muita consciência quando usamos
demasiado fogo sobre os países do mundo
porque não me enquadrava temos maior
densidade de ignições portanto fox
postos e pior ainda que muitas dessas
emissões são postas forma inconsciente
por isso tudo é que temos tantos em
dificuldades porque terá os seus
posicionamentos mais violentos e
catastróficos das telas de grande
pergunta que nos pomos que há de facto
uma gestante assistimos a situações de
incêndios que ultrapassam que
relacionamos animais têm capacidades que
estavam seja que são focos podemos dizer
em palavras mais do norte
nos onde está e velocidade de propagação
muito altas
o enredo de drogas entrada altura já
alguns minutos que não se irá propor
ação de 15 km por hora são coisas
praticamente impensável no domínio dos
estúdios fox o fogo violenta em 2009
prol da população
tal facto situações episódica que pregam
que elas sejam piores precaução pior por
situações particulares da metrologia o
ano que tínhamos com esta seca dólar
acumulava e por coisas que já vem de
muitos anos por uma situação de facto
uma organização dos nossos territórios
rurais
nós temos cada vez menos pessoas a viver
nos territórios do interior na zona
serrana
tvs - agricultura nessas áreas cada vez
menos pastorícia e portanto que temos é
que a paisagem vai ficar mobilizado em
termos total em termos de comportamento
do fogo
o comando do fogo são fundamentalmente
as estações costeiras ou material morto
o seu custo zero mas com design ou
afiliada manta morta cristiane el sol e
tem aspecto o território todo vai ficar
muito por cima tem mais árvores - várias
pessoas diferentes mas em termos do
descoberto oficial é impossível
tivemos ainda uma outra coisa que foram
sendo muito grande em 2003 e 2005 também
nos ajudaram como os lendários
territórios temos território muito vasto
em que o fogo não tem alterações de
comportamento
tudo isto associado pois há condições
climatéricas extremas fez com que
tivéssemos de facto focos de escura e
depois de alguns ventos parte quase que
tivemos e trovoadas secas tivéssemos
focus acima daquilo que estávamos
habituados a dizer nós sabemos que elas
existem existem
outra parte do mundo novo que nenhum
fenômeno força digamos quase
extraterrestre como fenômeno que
aconteceu de errado e que aqui aconteceu
há algumas que se sabia que podia
acontecer mesmo antes dela acontecer
sobretudo na situação dos incêndios de
outubro e portanto aí nós temos
exercícios possivelmente mais violento
xii catastrófico sobretudo nesta
situação particular desta
aquilo que nos interessa antes de mais
responder é como é que nós podemos
evitar que haja tantas mortes das
pessoas mortas em incêndios florestais
áreas envolvidas nós já estávamos mais
ou menos habituados em 2013 serão cerca
de 400 mil hectares mais 400 mil em 2005
r 300 mil hectares
fomos perdendo algumas vidas ao longo
deste tempo de deus nestes anos de vida
é importante em qualquer uma que espera
de extrema importância mas aqui nunca
nessa escala estão tivemos uma escala
como nunca tínhamos tido nós vamos
chegar em muitas razões históricas e
facto algumas das razões históricas
então nós temos nós estamos menos
preparados para viver com forro e
portanto estamos menos adaptados para
saber como atuar durante sua influência
nos custos
isso tem a ver também o que nós devemos
fazer para preparar os incêndios em
portugal não são um fenômeno fisiológico
não são excepção do conta a silvia que
acontece de dez em dez anos não são um
tumor terra em rua e acontece 300 em 300
anos
temos uma probabilidade nome delas
aconteceu em outros anos e diz que tem
mais extremos ao menos extremo oposto
isso nós temos que fazer é preparar as
pessoas têm aulas para apressar o
processo não é dizendo que ela se deve
ao projeto porque isso não se faz num
minuto ponto só tem que ser educadas e
educadas de forma positiva a partir da
escola nas situações que vão ter que
podem ter pela frente para saber como se
devem comportar
temos que procurar territórios pra que
isso para que elas estejam mais partidas
nós lembramos que temos no interior
neste momento eu vi em portugal desde a
obra relativamente pouco tempo pra cá
mas consegue ver uma situação tinha
visto na grécia em 2007
eu fiquei espantado com a circunstância
da grécia em 2007 com o mato entrar
atentos aglomerados as casas estavam
baseadas formatos em portugal em 2007
não acontecia desta forma o texto é o
filme que tem vindo a agravar esta
continuidade combustíveis nos então pela
casa adentro
temos pois também tão mal como esta
continuidade do espaço rural do espaço
florestal o espaço rural organizado
temos cada vez mais aglomeradas
procurados profissionais como população
mais velha como oposição ao menos capaz
portanto com baixa densidade e acima de
tudo com muito
construções do outras e essa digamos com
as críticas não são as piores são talvez
possam ser no comportamento deste ano as
postagens conselho fiscal é um fenômeno
relativamente rápido e portanto nós não
tivemos nada muito próximo das casas que
faça propagar o ec dessa casa uma casa
tofolli uma casa em condições de
habitabilidade em princípio no meu parto
as circunstâncias essas casas têm
capacidade para resistir a um estilo de
futebol que é claro que não tivemos uma
pilha de lenha o mou eram os mesmo por
cima dessa casa acontecem muitos novos
segurados das zonas raianas é que nós
temos tendo rumado jonas mattos som das
bandas e casas sem telhados em portas e
janelas e nessas o fogo não é rápido o
fogo instaladas e portanto pode durar
horas ou casas no incêndio nos incêndios
de outubro
guerreiro no dia 16 o ensino já tenha
passado no dia 15 casas encostadas às
outras habitações outras construções que
estavam multas que foram todas
construídas no dia 15 e que o fogo se
propagou por ligações de madeira que o
próprio proprietário esqueceram que eles
tinham como é normal e portanto no dia
16 ou casar depois do incêndio florestal
ter passado há mais de 12 horas em um
outro uma outra particularidade temos
olhar nossos temas nós queremos proteger
os aglomerados
nós temos que preparar o próprio
namorado envolvendo que essa brava ea
preparação do evento terá cobrado tem
que contar com a iniciativa local com as
pessoas que convivem com as pessoas que
estão em proximidade
nós temos 50 em tendência quando
acontece o fenômeno destes substituirmos
o estado os organismos organizações
substituir essas pessoas com a viver nem
fazer por elas e as que refletiram 5
acontece actualmente estas medidas têm
efeito facto imediato enquanto estiverem
duração ela só é eficaz mas quando o
estado se retira elas perdem eficácia
porque uma porção nossa situação é muito
forte
nós ao fim de 34 anos nós estamos no
mesmo estado em que estávamos antes e
portanto relativamente aos incêndios
florestais em gerais precisamos agora eu
diria que nós nos atrasamos e deixamos
de evoluir com foco no nosso foco serviu
durante me ajudar os nossos vizinhos
dela vivemos com ela em relativa paz 4
refogo esse posicionamento mais pró
natureza
e aqui o executivo nos últimos anos é
que o fogo tem tido comportamento de
cada vez pior por estes eventos
climáticos catastróficos termos ventos
que atravessa o norte da áfrica o
deserto do saara sahel e chegar aqui
carregado de poeiras e extremos como o
de um determinado segmento de baixas é
um fenômeno episódio mas pode acontecer
mais vezes
nós temos andado a tentar resolver o
problema dos incêndios sangue
conhecimento
temos trabalhado com muitos e mails com
algum dinheiro e utilizado muito pouco
racionalidade conhecimento avaliação
daquilo que estamos a fazer e temos
também as deixado que exista muita
consciência no uso do fogo
nós sabíamos nos dias 15 de outubro no
dia 14 de outubro logo que haver pessoas
que iriam fazer fogos porque porque
tradicionalmente todos os anos no final
do verão quando se anuncia que vai vir
chuva
sabemos que as pessoas indevidamente a
maior parte delas sem nenhuma razão
especial porque nas coisas do queimado
ao queimar um monte de os restos
agrícolas coisas dessas fazem fogo
só que está nós temos condições tão
particulares que devíamos ter sido
extremamente agressivos relativamente a
mensagem
nós não podíamos ter passado uma
mensagem porque de segunda feira avisa
que a chover e portanto que acabaram
rural simultaneamente queremos ter
influência no ofélia que esteve antes
quem passar por lá fica portanto
sabíamos que era um cerco
estávamos com o índice acumulado cerca
dos piores tempos nos últimos anos e não
ter visto meus senhores não se mata
não faço fogo estejam inquietos
protestos dentro das nossas casas
tiverem condições não façam de prato
isto matar eu acho que nós temos as
informações têm possível passadas ao
nível da comunicação social são
frequentemente doutora engenheiros
desde logo porque aquilo que nos
procuram mostrar sempre foram as casas
perderam sempre que as cenas na
califórnia mostramos as casas perderam a
incêndios na austrália mostrou das casas
perderam depois aqui frequentemente os
juristas no micro na mão é perguntar
quantas casas de querer esquece as
muitas vezes de perguntar efetivamente
quantas casas estão fora ensina os
normais não extraordinários de droga e
do final do ano doutor em seus normais
quanto às verdadeiras casas com pessoas
a viver aqui
isto o nome de transmitir estas casas
aqui fora notada a sua maneira
são condições que o problema de frente à
austrália posso viver no meio da
floresta de seu primeiro dia no meio do
mato se quiser vou guiado por lançar luz
formado por tudo
fazem me ensinaram temos
responsabilidade em que os responsáveis
dizem logo em caso de urgência nós não a
sociedade não se responsabiliza por si
nós temos que pensar que ter mecanismos
de passar alguma responsabilidade para a
atuação das próprias pessoas e portanto
temos fazer este trabalho
queremos trabalhar com a dissipação e
ser mais agressivo nas mensagens quando
queremos dizer não trabalha com o fogo
não ponham fogo por hipótese de votar e
ao mesmo tempo ter um serviço de fato
que seja eficaz em termos de
inteligência sobre a prevenção eo
combate quando nós temos situações de
emergência nós que gostaríamos ser
apoiados por voluntários ou por
profissionais e dentro dos profissionais
por profissionais ou por especialistas
nós continuamos apregoar a nossa
particularidade de termos um sistema de
voluntariado da proteção civil
meu deus eu acho que isto aqui na minha
cabeça não bate certo proteção civil e
voluntariado
são coisas quando também estão
desligadas
sim senhor que tenhamos voluntariados
york em termos de mãos para ajudar no
poder para ajudar na operação quanto
mais tivermos melhor
agora tem por lema quem manda tem que
saber aquilo que está a fazer em por
lena combate ou por essa opção é a
preparação das pessoas do território com
estas situações têm que ser os paulistas
mais alto grau é que sabe perfeitamente
o que é comportamento do fogo eo que
pode esperar de seu comportamento fogo
ela é bastante previsível e trabalhar
dessa forma a seguir ficar embaixo na
opressão temos voluntários profissionais
tenhamos toda a gente
uma das coisas que nós podemos também
foi a própria participação das
populações rurais muitas vezes no
combate aos incêndios florestais
portanto aí é preciso coragem e sejamos
todos vontade e mostramos vontade a
gente também sabe que sabemos fazer e
portanto a minha mensagem e espero que
seja uma perspectiva positiva depois de
tudo isto é difícil falar é e espero que
a gente evolua com estes incêndios para
atuar melhor o futuro
obrigado a todos
[Música]